good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
wednesday
you jumped up right in time it's brassin
of brass and strassen it's breath of
breaths and stress here at the morning
toast on
hump day which is my favorite day to be
in the presence of a bryce or a stress
because you know after the show
things get a little crazy
crazy
um actually speaking of bestiality i had
a dream i was in love with my horse
where did you get this horse and the
horse's name was odessa okay which is
weird um but like before bed last night
um
we were like playing a trivia game and
like one of the answers was odessa i
don't know if that is i think it's a
city yeah it is a city um and that was
my horse and apparently like it was a
horse from when i was a child and i was
reunited with the horse and the horse
also sang elvis oh that's that i know
why that is because last night i found
out that elvis comes out on hbo max next
week
wow you guys it's everything's coming up
because also top gun is available to
watch on demand now and elvis so once i
watch those two movies i will be totally
caught up and i will be able to knock
them off of my content plate that's
exciting check check check you're making
a list and checking it twice
to take
the doors down no no wait
no it's countess said it to take me down
yeah
but taking the doors down sounds better
yeah it does it's conflating the two the
two franchises um so that's here to say
that uh elvis will be on streaming next
week and i definitely will be watching
it because i just wasn't able to get my
ass to the theater this time same and i
have one thing to say
you ain't nothing but a dog
i get it
frog
frog frog frog
which i totally get by the way i think
she is saying frog if you were watching
the music video this weekend i asked you
if she was saying frog and as an artist
who's released music as well um
i get like i get it you know frog
actually yesterday was the three year
anniversary of her toes to the wow ones
a toast to the good luck and you know we
have so many new followers here because
literally like we are the official
podcast of tech talk um and i don't know
if like some of our new listeners know i
have some some bangers actually just two
um and one of them was released three
years ago yesterday it's called toast by
claudia ashrae available to stream
wherever you'd like and it's pretty um
it's pretty fire also i noticed in the
comments yesterday we must have some new
toasters because people are asking what
patreon is and we never explain what it
is we're just like go to patreon if you
want this that or the other thing wait
people want us to explain what patreon
is we would love to
never ask okay so patreon.com it's
pretty much like only fans but it's just
a different website where people do
different things a lot of podcasters use
it and where we post bonus content so we
do five extra episodes a month they're
different from this show it's not like
the fast five it's not what you see here
sometimes it's vlogs the podcast will
get into like a specific subject we'll
get into beauty plastic surgery history
history we're constantly discussing
history yeah so we'll pick a topic and
then expand on it we also do a lot of
general q and a's and we also do
probably two or three vlogs a month
depending on the month and what we're up
to so that's where you can like get to
know more about us when you're watching
the show and you're loving it but you're
like who are these girls yeah who are
the girls behind the mic i want 200 more
episodes from these girls where they're
being more personal more open we've been
saying 200 more episodes for like two
years i think it's probably four hundred
more so here we could do the math so
and by the way the morning toast podcast
that you're listening to now is monday
through friday totally free available
wherever you get your podcast so if you
want to a support your girlies and b pay
7.99 7.99 cents a month for five extra
episodes it's patreon.coming toast and
then you also get access to the patreon
community which is like full of other
toasters and as a patreon member you get
exclusive access to tickets which brings
me to my first point of the day the
pre-sale for my comedy tour the second
leg of not like other girls tour went
live this morning um for patreon members
so
charlotte we've got seattle we've got
portland it starts at 10 a.m local time
so you know the portland and the seattle
ones haven't started yet but charlotte
started durham started huntington long
island new york started um
yeah it's very exciting and then general
on sale for everyone starts friday and
hopefully there'll be some good tickets
left for you guys can't wait for that
and it looks to be about 250 episodes
that we have just doing quick math four
years of doing the toast
but we started patreon in may we started
the toast in april four years five
episodes a month
and then 12 months a year 60 times four
yeah and well i'm einstein
then um plus 10 episodes from may to now
right right
cool
yeah cool albert scurlies
yeah that's also something about us
we're kind of like mathematicians no
we're passionate about of course
celebrity pop culture and ourselves um
but we're also extremely passionate
about the sciences yeah math
um
industry yeah
revolution physics claudia will never
miss an opportunity to let you know that
she was almost a physics major
excuse me almost no i was a physics
major and right here for a year right
but unless you so that year doesn't
count no you only what you majored in no
no no no no
i'm not saying i graduated with a major
in physics i'm just saying for a period
of time i was a physics major i think
that's completely factually accurate
yeah
okay just don't even try to like strip
me of my accomplishments because i will
come for you i will come for you i'll
come for that tiny little neck okay as
long as you call it tiny it's yours i'll
wrap my big fingers around your tiny
little neck okay how tiny is it so small
i could crush it
we're also passionate about violence
we're also passionate actually about
reading which leads me to my next point
which is that the redheads recorded last
night and per usual it was an amazing
episode these girls they're just so
wonderful and the dynamic between the
four of us it's kind of like it reminds
me of the show friends it's like
everybody's so it's bad if it reminds me
of you of the show friends everybody's
obsessed like there's a character for
everyone i feel that no those girls
they've got charisma they really do and
they've got smarts oh speaking of
opinions speaking of you and reading
what is that you recommended
the worst book okay like the worst book
here's the thing you came to me for a
recommendation i said to you i don't
really have what you're looking for and
i'm going to do something that i never
do when i said this and i'm going to
recommend something that i haven't read
something that's on my want to read list
that has an interesting description that
maybe you would like you know i'm not
interested in the the details all i know
is that i ended up reading literally i
think the person who wrote this book sat
down and was like how many annoying dumb
infuriating characters can i fit into
one tiny little book and you know what
it was quite a lot i hated everyone i
hated the plot the ending oh my god so
dumb oh two stars and usually i never
finish i never give books two stars
because if it's that bad i won't finish
it no i give books two stars when it's
really bad but i made it to 50 and i'm
getting that goodreads book for my end
of year right and i just wanted to be
able to say like you know definitively
that the book you recommended was trash
and i didn't recommend it i said like i
would never have heard of it if it
wasn't for you okay we were
brainstorming and i said i'm gonna do
something i never do which is recommend
a book i haven't read so i i don't want
to like trash the book but i do like
want people like i don't want anyone to
have to experience what i experience
like should i say the name of my book no
because it's more personal than food in
like my
two star books like our some people's
five stars yeah no it's for sure it was
called greenwich park
the description looked good and the
controversy was really pretty stunning
you know also i have a really hard time
maybe this is you i've read i've read
like a bunch of books um
that take place in london and i have
like a really hard time imagining it or
really kind of understanding because i
have no idea what these neighborhoods
are i don't know how far they are from
each other i can't really picture it
unless it's written from the pov of an
american like something borrowed
well no something blue it takes place in
london but darcy is there and she's
american and she's like explaining it to
me got it so there's like a level of
understanding you need to have to like
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
yeah i feel that so many of the books
that i read are based in london
especially because my favorite author
one of my favorite authors is sophie
kinsella and she's a british girly and
confessions of shopaholic are all set in
london and i just go with it like i
don't pretend like i know what they're
doing okay so like i was reading this
this whole thing and like every cracker
is a digestive jackie do you know what
we want to go punting this weekend
do you know what that is no so at first
i was like whatever i'll figure it out
like contacts and then they like kept
saying it's why it's like click it hold
it down it needs to go boating like who
the [ __ ] knew that daddy yes but you
know um one of our favorite authors
sally hepworth is australian and all of
her [ __ ] takes place in australia but
she does a good job of being like oh
maybe not everyone is going to be
australian reading this and she explains
it like yeah or she'll be like so i live
here but my family lives on the gold
coast and i'm like so is that close
wherever you are
but i agree she paints a lovely picture
of australia
and i don't feel so out of the loop same
so that was one of the many issues
leanne moriarty writes from australia
too gorgeous place yeah um
honestly when i think of australia i
think of this iconic short-lived reality
show on netflix called instant hotel
where um they had people um compete who
had like different airbnbs like but like
they were cool niche airbnbs um they had
them all compete like they all stayed at
each other's airbnbs and like gave it a
grade and then someone would win at the
end it was just like i feel like i talk
about this all the time this incredibly
annoying mother-daughter duo bondi her
name was bondai and they had a condo in
bondi beach and me and ben were obsessed
and there was also this gay couple leroy
and um i forgot his name and they were
so obnoxious the pillow yeah and you
always say i'm like him because i have
to bring my own pillow they were so
snotty they went everywhere like there
was just some people who had like modest
airbnbs and they put their whole life's
work into it and leroy and his partner
who's my name i can't remember like
we're so [ __ ] snobbish like so
disgusting the very last episode we get
to their airbnb and it's
literally like a suburban home like in
the middle of some random suburb with
like a waterfall in front it was so
janky and we're like you two have been
so obnoxious to everyone like this is
what you were working with the whole
time
safe to say they did not win but justice
for instant hotel bring it back
yeah i agreed i also think of our lips
are sealed when i think of australia of
course iconic mary kate nationally
that's the one that's the one i hope
that they're happy with that portrayal
of their country uh they must be it must
be on some you know like list of
approved media when they they were in
the witness protection program in that
movie right
so good yeah and he was from a country
called yet ugly
what he was from who was one of the guys
who was like chasing them down he's from
yet ugly
[Laughter]
oh my god that's funny and i'm sure in
some recess of my mind that's where i
get auntie comes from right you're
welcome
what can i say except you're welcome
um
oh i forgot to tell you so we had dinner
at your house last night and we pretty
much spent the entire evening trying to
get michaela to say claudia um and i
know it's a hard name to say and i'm
trying not to take it personal that i'm
the last person um whose name she said
even though i've literally been in her
house for almost two weeks um and when
she went to bed last night you know zach
shapiro picks her up and then like
hands her to everyone to say good night
and she like laid on my belly and i she
literally whispered in my ear claudia i
swear to [ __ ] god like gaslighting
you because she won't say it publicly
and she's like not going to she's going
to make everyone think that you're crazy
by saying she said it and we're like no
she hasn't we didn't hear it the cool
thing about olivia um and zach is that
they're not emotionally manipulative
like us and they believed me
that's like you guys she she literally
like leaned in for a hug
kind of like you know like a child in a
scary movie like claudia the power of
christ compels you
and then she went to bed and i haven't
seen her this morning because you feel
different now that it happened that's
really been your goal you know i don't
feel different if anything i'm just like
that was it
you didn't want to say that claudia i
love you so much thank you for being an
amazing auntie yeah
it's fine that's nice we're working out
our differences me and michaela eden
sassoon the lisa marina to my eating
cessoon yeah
and that's a patreon joke so if you
don't get it join patreon speaking of
eating tesoon so i'm reading this book
oh yeah uppercut by carrie white and
she's a celebrity hairdresser
much like doll envy dolls all over it
really like here and there actually it's
not main character or anything but like
she talks about you know the other
people around her like this person came
from vidal what's vidal doing over in
the uk he's doing these like blunt
haircuts that's the inspiring looks here
that's so interesting feed also soon is
such an interesting like um
celebrity you know and does that hair
care brand still exists for sure yeah
it's no paul mitchell but they're all
pretty good yeah that's
do you think eating tattoos has a lot of
money from the vidal sassoon
legacy i believe this is googlable so
and did she have other siblings that she
had to split it away feel like she
probably has siblings vidal sassoon net
worth yep
net worth
oh i think there's a vidal sassoon
documentary he has a net worth of 200
million wow
and so and he's not alive right
um
it doesn't i'm not seeing oh who did he
leave his money to oh great great
question and oh and also the next
question is how much is eaten from
beverly hills right yeah he has two
surviving children oh 100 million fourth
wife rhonda were entitled to the
entirety of his state and assets oh
fourth wife that throws a wrench in the
hall thing you know yeah so they say
eden's net worth it's just 20 million
nice
but she's also an entrepreneur so she
might have like put
you know
lost all the money in some dumb venture
about christmas
yeah cool cool that tracks for sure
um so that's your hair history lesson of
the day yeah we've got a great show it's
wednesday which means we're doing deer
toasters which is one of my personal
favorite segments here at the morning
toast our advice segment at the end of
the show we will read three prompts from
three toasters in need of our help and
we will do our absolute best to deliver
some really sage and sound advice um if
you ever want to write in it's dear
toasters gmail.com totally anonymous you
can write it about literally anything
you want literally literally can't
guarantee it'll get chosen no no i mean
if it's good and please don't be writing
essays like this episode our episodes
like we try and keep them like around an
hour if you're writing me a whole
megillah even if it's the craziest [ __ ]
i've ever heard in my [ __ ] life i
can't read it yeah but if you loved your
toasters and like or you're feeling shy
about your dear showsters every so often
we do a deer toaster's patreon episode
where it's all your toasters from
requests from our patreon members who
have a better chance of getting selected
we can be a little more long-winded
it's a great time but for the main show
like keep it tight only need to know
information you know
nothing's that important so without
further ado
even though he isn't here next to brutal
theo's here
oh yeah you guys we ship down the
theater pillow to jackie's florida
studio so that when i'm back in new york
i'll have a piece of bryce with me
she'll have my bruno pillow and i'll
have her theo pillow and then we'll have
our real dogs and so everyone will be
together so i guess this is the official
you know passing of the baton
now i've got brass and stress on my
chair brass and straws
you know what everyone's like you need a
centerpiece for the table right here we
have one yeah we have one right now you
know a
brief observation before we dive in i
feel like in our florida episodes in our
florida eras
we have we're in our florida era 100
we have not sang that much
maybe that's why our numbers are so high
i wonder why that is
and i do want to thank everyone for um
the non-stop work they've been doing to
subscribe to us on youtube we're getting
much closer i think we're at 95k and
when i started this whole journey a
couple weeks ago like we were so far we
were at 80. so bullying works and that's
the lesson from today's episode um and
i'm feeling really good about it like
also i
a bunch of youtubers
who um listen to the show have actually
reached out to me it's like some growth
hack
um tips and tricks and one of those is
uploading to youtube shorts i should do
that which i do believe has really
helped our growth um
so i don't know which it is the bullying
or the shorts but i'm gonna continue to
do both [ __ ] subscribe you ugly wench
if you're listening as a podcast even if
you're in your car when you get to your
destination pull out your phone i'm
talking to you in your car who's like no
she's not talking to me sarah listen up
if your name is sarah and you're driving
in your car listening to this podcast
when you get to your destination you
have to describe to you subscribe to
youtube and we can see the names and if
it's not all sarah's today yeah like
you're done there will be no episode
tomorrow we will we will withhold our
talent
until we hit 100k that's what we should
do no more episodes until 100k and that
would mean only like five or four
thousand of you have to get on your
gmail and subscribe i think that's a
good idea and not desperate at all
and has no ability to backfire
okay so now without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you do need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
clinique if you have dark spots it can
often feel like a vicious cycle as soon
as one phase another one will pop up but
you can break the cycle with the
clinique even better clinical dark spot
interrupter this powerful serum works on
melanin rich to fair skin and helps
visibly correct dark spots such as acne
marks while protecting from future
discoloration so i'm a dark spot girly
especially um in the summer
it brings out like these dark patches
under my skin and i find them to really
bother me um and i've been using
clinique since last summer actually i
maybe
i can't remember when i started but
there's a visible difference and i
thought it was just one of those things
like you just lived with like you didn't
there was no like fix for it um and
there is an action really have not
struggled with it in the last couple of
months thanks to clinique 94 um
demonstrated an improvement in radiance
and visible skin tone including acne
marks in eight weeks you can see a 39
visible reduction in dark spots in 12
weeks it features their proprietary
brightening molecule and vitamin c for a
more even-looking skin tone including
acne marks one thing about me it's like
if you're putting vitamin c in your
skincare like i will be purchasing
there's just something gorgeous about it
yeah and i know this is like not
scientifically or factually correct but
it makes me feel tan
interesting is it because there's
something that harnesses the power of
the sun yeah and it's just like maybe
it's a mindset it's like a placebo it's
a state of mind yeah um their powerful
brightening serum for melanin rich to
fair skin to visibly improve uneven skin
tone and interrupt the look of future
dark spots so you can get even better
clinical dark spot interrupter today
available at clinique.com clinique is
spelled c l i n i q u e dot com for the
even better clinical dark spot
interrupter today's episode is also
brought to you by bowling branch
bowlin branch uses the best 100 organic
cotton threads on earth for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep
their sheets aren't just buttery
breathable and impossibly soft to start
they get softer with every wash we are
both this is a bowling branch house yes
my apartment in new york is a bowling
branch house i don't like to stay in a
room that is not a bowling branch house
thankfully i'm staying at olivia's
which is a bowling branch house i have
the signature collection i think that's
what you have too that's what i have
that's what i have in my bed here now
that's what i have in my guest room for
you and everybody loves it it's for
everyone it's the signature hem sheets
from roland branch it's their best
seller for a reason they use the highest
quality threads on earth for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep
their sheets are made with threads so
luxurious they're beloved they have been
beloved by three us presidents
not us being presidential not us
sleeping in the president's bed
they feel buttery to the touch so you
can get 15 off your first set of sheets
when you use promo code toast at
bowlandbranch.com
when it comes to bed like this is where
you don't skimp out like you get the
best of the best and bowling branch is
the best and our 15 off with code toast
will help you retrieve achieve the bed
of your dreams so bowling branches
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch
promo code
toast
amazing thing remember like when we were
in school growing up and teachers would
like lick their finger so unnecessary to
get um like the pages to stop sticking
while obviously now in kobe like that's
disgusting it's also just like i
remember being like get your [ __ ]
tongue away from me wench like it was so
such a wenchy behavior it was such a
violation yeah it was and just like
something about their particular tongue
something about like a school room just
made everything dry you know like that
is just unnecessary
and then sometimes like if you got your
paper and you were the top one that had
like the mark on it it was moist yeah
you had a fingerprint and i know we have
a lot of teacher toaster so i just i'm
curious to know if that fad has i don't
think contemporary teachers do that me
neither
i hope i pray i wonder what that was
about because it's like people handle
paperwork all the time but only teachers
lifted their fingers yeah no and their
like glasses would be at the bottom of
their nose and they would be licking and
it was just like it was really as if
school wasn't traumatizing enough that
was um that was really unnecessary now
that i think about it
not cool teachers not cool
core memory um 100 like um do you have a
teacher in your mind right now who
you're like remembering do it no oh i do
i am you just have like a favorite
teacher who put everything on jackie
it's that teacher who i spoke about in
my dirty jeans comedy special yeah you
just love naming her for all your life's
trauma behind the scenes tip the name i
used in
my comedy special is not her real name
they said i could get sued if i did even
though like it was a positive story for
her um but no yeah only real ones now
okay now are you ready to get into the
stories they're actually pretty good
today oh i had i had sent you a story
from vulture
from last night
oh yeah i thought you wanted me to read
it like for my personal life you didn't
say for the toast oh i thought it was
implied it's fine because it's really
niche
um but i just thought it was interesting
do you want to just update us so i feel
like i've been talking about this a lot
recently especially on breaking bread
which oh we have tonight wednesday
today's wednesday we have breaking bread
but it's at five o'clock tonight yes
because rolled comes first well it
wasn't working for me and that's fine
and other people were like suggesting
why don't you move the time so the time
is now five o'clock eastern time join us
it'll be so much fun and then as always
it'll be available on friday and we
support mamas yeah we do otherwise mamas
get us
didn't support mamas i've been talking
about this story because i just find it
really interesting even though i think
it's like a niche side of tick tock
about the jake novak story so for those
who don't know this kid jake novak who
makes like
youtube videos where he like sings and
choreographs and writes lyrics to like
he's trying to be funny um and one of
his went viral on tick tock because he
was basically making this video when he
heard about all the people leaving snl
he was making like an audition for
himself and like it was so cringy and
like it went viral and everyone was like
blowing him up but at the end of the day
like he was just like you know doing his
art you know putting himself out there
he was putting himself out there well
how did the song go you used to sing it
all the time
i want to be the next snl cast member
so here's why i should be a contender my
name is jake novak
i don't know the rest of it um and then
people just like went off people became
obsessed with the cringiness of it then
started looking at some of his older
videos resurfacing like this cringiness
um there was like i think he didn't do
anything wrong and like the hate that he
got was so
like the magnitude of it was so crazy
compared to like he was just like
putting himself out there like maybe he
thought i could just see his grandma
being like what if you just made a video
for lorne right um and it was like it
was earnest and it was sweet um but then
like you know some of his old videos
like he did one about like school
shootings and it was like really um
insensitive you know
children dying in the schools like it
was really weird um but again like i
think his intentions were pure you know
okay he was just trying to like make art
yeah it's not mal intended it's just
not
but the way the internet ascended upon
him like and he descended descended
thank you he is like his real job is um
he's a performer a singer in like a
barbershop quartet at disneyland and
people were like showing up and like
harassing him it got so out of control
and he posts videos once a week every
wednesday and he has not been heard from
since that snl video which was seven
weeks ago so now the narrative on tick
tock has changed like hashtag where is
jake novak and people have been speaking
out like you guys literally bullied him
off the internet showing up to
disneyland like you guys are evil and
it's just like obviously now the
conversation has changed but vulture
landed an interview with the mysterious
jake novak and he told them everything
he was like this has literally been the
worst time of my life like people
harassing my family members literally
people like were this is really sad like
people were reaching out to him making
fake emails and fake websites pretending
to be lauren michaels like and i think
for a while like
it got really sad and really and really
bad and it's just like it's an
interesting case study on like virality
on the internet yeah um and his
interview with vulture was um it was
really sad and then of course like he
had old tweets so everyone's like no we
don't feel bad for him which is not like
a valid um thing for a normal human
being to say
so it's just been like a crazy journey
that i think we've now come to an end
with like we've heard from jake novak he
got an interview on vulture and it was
really interesting to read everything
that he's been through since this one
dumb
cringy but not evil video came out that
just made me like really sad that's why
i sent it to you i thought you would
find it interesting it was like i had to
read it on reader view and yeah
i was just doing something else yeah
that i can't remember and i wasn't
invested in the story to begin with and
now i'm depressed no it's really it's
like it's a terrible surprise to me with
them showing up to his barbershop
quartet no and i saw a video of him at
his barbershop quartet he was like
having so much fun i want to cry no i
know he was obviously just like
passionate about his art
and took it a little too far which
haven't we all taken our art too far
hello the morning toast it's called
being an artist it's called being an
artist didn't davinci cut his ear off
and it's just sad it's really it's a
modern day da vinci
or was it van gogh van gaal cut his ear
off
but he is a modern davinci that too
so i just thought you'd find like that
because i've been talking about it at
least personally with you so much yeah i
thought you'd find the end of the story
quite um quite interesting i'm upset i
know i wish i didn't know this i'm sorry
it was upsetting for sure internet is so
disgusting
like why can't we just leave it on the
internet that's the thing it's like you
want to write like your funny mean like
comment about the cringiness whatever
but to show up to his work to make these
fake emails like get a [ __ ] life and
then of course it like always life into
like death threats telling him he should
kill himself like of course why why did
i like the video no did it make me
cringe to the
largest extent yes would i ever message
him you should kill yourself like
people are not okay no i mean people
aren't okay
it's so sad
that's just really not the foot i want
to start with i'm sorry i'm sorry i just
i forgot to talk to you about it this
morning if you had added it to the
docket
well i didn't so what did you add to the
doctor we actually have some some really
good stories today so first up demi
lovato is using she her pronouns as well
as they them now so demi lovato is back
to using she her pronouns a year after
coming out is not in binary and sharing
her preference to go by they them the
singers shared on the spout podcast
tuesday that she came to the decision
podcast making news of course haven't
heard of this particular one me neither
but i will be subscribing
because we subscribe and we support
other podcasts like uh a step forward
for one podcast is a step forward for
all podcasts agreed um she came to the
decision because she is quote such a
fluid person okay further explaining why
she previously adopted they them she
said her energy last year was quote
balanced in my masculine and feminine
energy
when i was faced with the choice of
walking into a bathroom and it said
women and men i didn't feel like there
was a bathroom for me because i didn't
feel necessarily like a woman the singer
added i didn't feel like a man i just
felt like a human lovato said choosing
to identify by they them pronouns
pronouns at one point for her was about
feeling human at your core
then she said quote recently i've been
feeling more feminine and so i've added
she her again but i think what's
important is like nobody's perfect
she said everyone messes up pronouns at
some point and especially when people
are learning it's just all about respect
okay i really can't stress enough how
much i appreciate that because obviously
like i try and keep up with everyone's
pronouns but not i'm not always gonna
get it right and like sometimes
especially like you know um you know the
certain type of internet user like
usually like white women like thinking
they're saving the earth like when we
talk about halsey or we talk about
trisha paytas i know both of them go by
she her and they them pronouns so more
often than not for me like i'm gonna go
with she her just because it's
simpler for me to remember and of course
like they say it's fine so i
use it um
halsey goes my name like i'm
intentionally out here trying to
undermine someone's identity which is
not the [ __ ] case first of all so i
appreciate um and i feel like whenever
she talks about her pronouns she always
throws that in the end like i understand
people are gonna like take a minute to
adjust and i appreciate that because it
could be especially when like you talk
about celebrities for a living and you
talk so fast like you're not always
thinking
what pronoun they identify as um i
appreciate the the leeway um she gives
us here
and always wanting what's best for demi
you know like live your life girly
yeah
do what you got to do i'm curious if
you've seen any what the people are
feeling about this decision well demi
lovato is just currently like not in a
well-liked phase of her career and of
course we all know it started with the
with the diet um frozen yogurt right um
so i don't think people really have like
people really care
not care but like i don't think people
right now are disgusting discussing
whether you know demi's pronoun like i
don't think that's what people are
talking about when it comes to demi
lovato i think they're talking about
like
we're not into demi right now
guys i think that's the general and
maybe i'm wrong so
because i was curious what the
temperature would be about this
because it
doesn't seem like something that like
one should do lightly it's just like
today i was feeling this way and
tomorrow i'm feeling that way and i feel
like um
for
maybe people in the trans or non-binary
community this is kind of like an
affront to know that like
i'm going to be this today tomorrow and
also like de-transitioning is a huge
deal and we read a book about it for the
red hat transition baby and learn more
about like detransitioning and like uh
the role that it plays like in the trans
community so i would imagine that like
someone like her
doing this
in this way and just kind of being it
feels flippant about it okay so i see
how like you could
see it that way but i think again i'm
not a part of the community so i don't
know what the general consensus is but i
think they embrace fluidity like gender
not being like a construct and like
almost like not having to abide by one
or the other and i think like they
embrace that type of i don't think they
would see it as flippant i think they
would see it as fluid which i think uh
the you know the non-binary community
embraces i think again i'm not
non-binary and i don't know like a ton
about how they feel but i think that the
general consensus from the community is
like do whatever makes you feel good
whenever okay i think okay and if you're
able to explain to us like in the
comments and like not in a you know
karen karen sort of way i'm genuinely
curious like if this is
no but i think the question that you
were getting at that i do agree with is
like what is the non-binary community's
thoughts on demi in general as like
because remember that the trans
community was like not happy about
having caitlyn jenner as like a you know
kind of not a spokesperson but a
representative for the community and is
the non-binary community like happy you
know to have demi be like a very public
face of pronouns and non-binary
ness yeah i don't know i i don't think
people like right now are like loving
demi um i just think her public image
has been like a little chaotic in the
last couple of years and people might be
fatigued by that but i don't know if
that also is if that has anything to do
with this and if it's uh you know
shaping how people view her decision
yeah yeah but i am genuinely curious so
lmk lmk
are you ready for our next story
crazy
celeb memoir news jeannette mccurdy has
written uh her memoirs i've been waiting
for janet mccurdy to like deadass spill
every fact about her childhood in a
concise way for a long time she's
alluded to it but she's never really
like been out there about it okay well
her memoir is called i'm glad my mom
died i did know that that was the name
of it i thought that was you know very
catchy and she is on the cover holding
an urn a pinker
so i'm assuming her relationship with
her mom was not was not good so um
entertainment weekly has
received an excerpt from the book where
she talks about her for icarly audition
like auditions before that and how like
it affected her mom she talked about one
audition where she didn't get the job
and how her mom like had a breakdown
okay when she got icarly like she
thought it was gonna be like the best
thing ever because finally her mom would
be happy
and um oh that's really sad yeah it
seems really really sad but this is the
book it's on
sale on august 9th so
you should read it yeah well that i
actually might read it if i can find the
time yeah i wonder if the book is about
mostly her relationship with her mom i
mean even just that thing you just said
it's like so much pressure to put on a
little kid and can really [ __ ] you up so
i imagine her relationship with her mom
never you know got better um
and i i do think that would be
interesting to read but also you know as
someone of a nickelodeon historian like
i'm extremely interested in the
you know
i don't want to say it i don't get in
trouble i don't know why oh you think
that she'll talk about well i don't know
if she will but she i think of all the
people who
are in public life post that nickelodeon
time um she's been the most vocal but
still not in a really kind of clear and
lucid way and a book is a great place to
do that
yeah
yeah and the quotes on the covers gerard
carmichael calls it impressively funny
and lena dunham calls it an important
important cultural document not to ruin
the book for you no no um who's the
first person gerard carmichael oh oh
comedian
um
yeah lena dunham that's that's
interesting
yikes
um cool cool i do think it's interesting
like you know icarly is now i think they
just got renewed for their third season
in their like revival she's not a part
of it though she's like available
uh but she's not interested she also had
said on a podcast years ago that like
most of the time she spent doing that
show those shows i carly sam and cat
like she was embarrassed
for the content that was being put out
and you know what like respect because i
agree
i agree you need to read this book you
need to report back because you're
looking for books to read like celebrity
memoirs yeah you're always wanting to
hear from jeanette yeah no and um
there's like this is a a person whose
story like i have followed for many
years so you will be reporting back on
august 10th that's what you're saying i
really wish her the best i get the vibe
that like her time on nickelodeon was
so damaging to her mental health like
and the fact that and what i find so
interesting about this whole
nickelodeon thing is like
there are people from the show who have
like very quietly like spoken out about
it and like it was so damaging for them
and then there are other people like
ariana grande like she came from there
too and there's like so many people who
are thriving doing amazing and so many
who are like the exact opposite so i
just don't understand how that works
well i imagine it has a lot to do with
your family and like your child starting
right like what is your home life like i
think ari's mom is like she's so close
with her mom so she had a really good
support system support system she has
her brother who she's really close with
so but if you are like you know you have
a stage mom and you are the sole earner
in your family like it can go the other
way yeah i actually remember watching a
million years ago an interview um that
kiki palmer did about that like how
being the youngest and like the the
income earner in your family is so toxic
and like it can really and more often
than not it does lead to like
irreparable damage within the family
yeah so that must happen a lot with like
child stars yeah and i think ari like
also came from money so she didn't have
that it wasn't as big of a deal but like
no when when the when the kid is the one
who brings you like out of a bad
financial place it's very toxic yeah you
know josh peck talked a little bit about
it in his book but him and his mom he
was raised by a single mom and they were
like so close and he was the one who
wanted to go out for every audition and
she was like are you sure are you sure
and then when he started making money
like he he was so excited about it just
so he could pay his mom back it was so
sweet like
and
and i think like to this day like
everything he does like he does for his
mom it was really sweet josh mc's book
is like one of
a celebrity memoir that like i keep
thinking about it was so good i really
recommend i absolutely have to read it
because the thing about a celebrity
memoir is like even if it's not someone
that you're so obsessed with like i'm
reading this carrie white book and like
it's so good i don't even know who she
was right i didn't even know it was a
celebrity memoir just lauren bostic said
to read it and it was like about
the subtitle is like my glamorous life
in hollywood
here i go yeah i thought maybe it was
fiction
um so i think that
when someone has a story to tell anyone
doesn't even have to be a celebrity
someone you're a fan it's just a memoir
yeah
it's worth reading right like josh pecks
had like so many layers like of course
you want to read about the drake and
josh of it and that was super
interesting but like the four years
where he was like had a terrible
addiction problem then the weight loss
like there were so many layers of it it
was so good
okay so you'll be reading this and he's
funny like you'll be reading it yeah i'm
gonna try yeah okay i haven't been in
like my celebrity memoir you know mood
recently
but there are many i want to pick up
like i've been meaning to read the colin
jose one for like a thousand years i've
heard it's good
but i just never even like i never i
never even like to start typing it in my
kindle you know what i mean i think you
should read that no
no
wait for i was gonna say you should read
that today because you're a book a day
and you just finished a book that you
hate but i don't want you to read a
memoir and then like get fatigued
because you need to do the homework on
this for us okay okay are you ready for
our next story which is so sad like
today's episode is just depression okay
what is it
ferris bueller actress edie mcclerg is a
victim of the elder abuse her family
claims you know her from faculty
of course yeah just google her what was
her role she was like the school
secretary yes oh my iconic bob like she
had the tracy turned blood hair yes or
did tracy have her hair oh great
question but the family of actress edie
mcclurk has claimed that she's a victim
of elder abuse in court documents seen
by the post the family of the star who
lives in l.a and suffers from dementia
allege that she was abused by a man
claiming to be a longtime friend who
reportedly attempted to take her out of
california to marry her the documents
filed in the superior courts of
california named the abuser the alleged
abuser as michael ramos who has
reportedly been living at her home since
2017. she is 76 years old according to
the documents he is unemployed and does
not pay rent or any expenses and
was able to finagle his way into her
life reportedly attempting to move her
out of california in order to marry her
despite her dementia diagnosis the
documents also claim that he allegedly
quote sexually assaulted her current
caregiver with a report filed with the
la police department in addition the
caregiver was worried that he has or may
be assaulting the conservative and that
she may not even know that it's
happening to her oh my god stop wait um
this is literally the worst story why
wait i'm like so upset
elder abuse of course any abuse is
horrible but there's something
particularly evil
about elder abuse yeah whether it's like
financial physical sexual and this
sounds like it's all three
um is so [ __ ] evil if i ever meet
this man in a dark alley like i will
literally i would kill him like that's
so [ __ ] evil yeah ugh
ugh i'm upset to any person like not
even the fact that she's famous like and
you know what's so sad is like elder
abuse is extremely common yeah and we're
only hearing about this because
she's like yeah you could say
foreign very this is so upsetting
so upsetting at the very least i hope it
shines the spotlight though on lg on
elder abuse but i agree anybody who
would
take advantage of someone who's elderly
vulnerable who like can't defend
themselves and also doesn't even have
the presence of mind right is disgusting
evil should burn in hell yeah for real
that was like that story remember from a
few years ago
of the coma patient who was pregnant of
course that was a story that changed the
nation yeah oh my god also stories of
change nation i was on tik tok and i'm
telling you they tell you you don't find
out anything interesting on tick tock
not true have you heard about carolyn
bryant
you know the story of emmett till the 14
year old boy during
the civil war okay so i saw that she
emerged from her house she's alive i
didn't even know that and the daily mail
got paparazzi pictures of her she's like
94 or whatever and now people are saying
like she she's in hospice so it's like
are we gonna um
should they prosecute her because she's
like 95 and technically i think when
you're like a certain age or you're like
really sick they don't prosecute you
because you're gonna die soon but
everyone's like no get her um i could
not believe that this woman was alive
because i was just watching when i was
in the airport they were doing an
interview with whoopi goldberg
she is um a producer on it they're
making a movie about emmett till and i
was like damn that's so crazy so like
the story was like fresh in my mind and
then i'm like wait cause you feel like
this stuff happened so long ago yeah
this [ __ ] is still alive so people
didn't know she was alive or like she
was just saying i think the last
sighting of her or last we heard it was
like 2004 okay um so nobody really knew
if she died or what she was up to but
the daily mail i guess was like
following her around and they got
paparazzi pictures of her that's crazy
it's crazy and they say she's 94 in
hospice and in the picture she looked
sprightly as [ __ ] i just want to say she
looks like she and by the way if you're
in hospice i don't think you're like
walking around she was walking her dog
and the daily mail like reporter went up
to her and her son was there like
standing in front of her like no comment
no comment
it's a crazy story like it's crazy i
couldn't believe it how did the daily
mail even know where to go she lives in
kentucky i don't know the daily mail is
crazy yeah
but like she's been obviously living
completely under the radar
for years and i don't think anybody knew
of like a physical sighting of her since
2004. wow but i guess they knew she was
alive because like death records or
public records somebody has been keeping
up with this um and they found her wow
it was gave me such a chill like it was
such a crazy story she is such a crazy
story yeah
well her next story switching gears
selena gomez will reboot melanie
griffiths 80s comedy working girls say
reports
selena gomez is reportedly in talks to
remake working girl the 1988 mike
nichols directed comedy starting melanie
griffith and harrison ford one thing
about me these days like selena gomez is
doing something boom support it
subscribing i've been living for selena
and i've been keeping an eye out for her
too oh you've got to you gotta keep an
eye out for leaner i mean this is a
great first of all a working girl reboot
it's what the world needs even though
she's probably like working from home
and like oh i hope it's not like she's
not doing okay no it's because honestly
it has potential to be like um
like younger wait why can't i remember
the name of that show
the one i loved on freeform
bold type type it's younger it's the
same thing yeah it's giving bold type
right um i hope it's not like coconut
like if it's like 20 22 she's working
from home girl no no hopefully it's like
she's fabulous in like a high rise in
some major city reality today like i
think that the reason why working girl
in 1988 was because it was captured it
captured the spirit of the working girl
in 1988 and i think so many girls
watching and it's like that's me with my
sneakers and my eyes right right the
blazer the suit but that you
know fashion girly energy doesn't really
exist it doesn't exist right now yeah
that's so true oh no i'm upset maybe we
need selena to bring it back 100
um have they cast anyone else joan
cusack who's playing joan cusack uh
i'm not sure but it will air on hulu
according to entertainment weekly wait
did you see that celina was hanging out
with francia raisa the friend who gave
her the kidney who like they haven't
been friends for literally three years
then they were out making tick tocks
like everything's fine oh good yeah that
made me happy because that was nefarious
that was nefarious like you couldn't say
it without this friendship gives you a
kidney as a friend for life right so
what happened but now the girlies seem
to be doing really well
okay good together which was a huge
relief for me in my new celinator era
but i think that also helps you in your
new era because that was something that
just like wasn't added sitting right it
wasn't sitting right now everything sits
right and we're all good we're all good
we're sitting perfectly
i really look forward to hearing more
about this project yeah and selena's
partnership with hulu has turned out to
be extremely fruitful obviously only
murders um i'm loving this selena's just
been killing it i was actually um
scrolling tic toc of course yesterday
and like a fan account was posting clips
of her from selena plus chef
um and then it really got me thinking
like she has not dated publicly or at
least like with the celebrity in such a
long time let me get off the list yeah
let's well we have to add her to the
list yeah we do i feel like she's
extremely cautious of dating in the
public eye and who she chooses obviously
because her relationship
because her relationship with justin was
so terrible we already had this
conversation where i said selena gomez
and michael b jordan i love that no
selena gomez and chris evans was like
they were briefly linked not in any like
confirmed way but ever since then it's
all i can think about yeah there's
really not really someone for her here
and she's like so famous that she really
would have a hard time finding a like a
commoner
try a businessman bow she needs yeah
like a like um
like a tech she needs like an evan
spiegel
yeah evan spiegel evan spiegel is
literally like the dream yeah who's the
ceo of be real
love except i don't think it's like
successful enough for him to like have
enough money okay sorry wow look at me
or her um
like the next big thing you know or the
ceo of tick tock or something you know
she loves tick tock oh does she yeah
maybe taylor swift's brother
okay alexis
is that a girl i'm not sure
because
images oh
no it's a man is he cute like kind of i
mean you can't really like see
but here he is he's the ceo of the bb
extremely cute
he's fit
perfect
perfect found it selena set it up
yeah set it up i like this um working
girls like
usually like i roll my eyes at reboots
and stuff but like this is cute this is
cute i mean what else is cute solo stuff
oh now that you have like a full-on
backyard you can whip yours out
year-round
life's best moments happen around a
roaring fire and because and a smokeless
fire pit from solo stove makes your
outdoor moments even more memorable
so
prior to jackie actually having a home
in a backyard we wear solo stove like
portable girlies that's a great thing
about solo strobe it's a smokeless fire
pit you can really take it with you
anywhere it's not heavy at all or if you
are you know you have the luxury of
having a backyard it's perfect for
year-round fires which is what you're
going to do now um you can upgrade your
backyard with a solar stove fire pit and
create story-worthy moments without the
fireside fumes their stainless steel
construction is designed to regulate
airflow and burn more efficiently so
little smoke you'll wonder how there's
so much fire it's the perfect catalyst
for getting outside and spending more
time with family and friends you can
build lasting memories around a solo
stove fire pit they are brilliantly
engineered to be easy to use and they're
built to last they're so confident that
you'll love it they offer a lifetime
warranty and a 30-day free return policy
right now you can get big discounts on
all fire pits during solo stove's summer
sale you can use promo code toast at
solostove.com for an extra 10 off that's
solo stove.com promo code toast for ten
dollars off on top of their incredible
summer sale discounts
great thank you for that our fifth and
final story
is a real human interest story love from
people magazine of course twins who
marry
and gave birth to twins twin to marry
twins gave birth to genetic siblings
they say they're
wait
what yeah because twins
identical twins have the same dna so if
it's you know
let's say it's jane and john well jane
and it's jackie and claudia okay have
the same dna yeah and silvia and margo
olivia and margot have the same dna too
so
if you do jackie and olivia
it's
the same dna the brother is it a
different family
no no olivia okay their kids are all
that was a bad example because now we're
getting oh i get it because their kids
are 50
of each of them and their fifty percent
are all the same right right right so
what does that make the two
kids twins siblings
not twins not twins they don't have
identical dna
no because it could have been any combo
did each couple give birth to single
kids or twins singles got it and so
those two single kids have the exact
same dna
yes how has this never happened before
i mean you would have to find identical
to maybe it's happened in the history of
time but there was no people magazine to
source them and write it up and tlc to
give them a show
you have to have identical twin females
and identical twin males who all love
each other enough to get married to get
married and have kids so the cousins are
also siblings and the siblings are also
cousins yeah that is crazy and this was
something these
twins did intentionally like they sought
out this result it wasn't just
happenstance that they both fell in love
with identical twins yeah they realized
you know they said quote we were like oh
my gosh our dream has come true how
lucky are we that we get to live it the
sisters had always wanted to marry
identical identical twins and share
their lives together the journey to
start this heartwarming moment has been
better than they could have imagined
it's like a weird dream to have you know
some people dream of going to space
becoming a pop star
it's just weird to like dream of having
kids who are
100
dna matched when you're an identical
twin you have interesting
interests
yeah and like just your
your take on life is different it's
different you know everyone has things
about them that frame what they think
about you know what
how they live their life
just you know random quirks about them
and i think being a twin is like a
really big i would say for me it's like
being a redhead like yeah has completely
changed like it's integral to who you
are who i am for sure for sure um this
is just a crazy story i read the
headline and i just i didn't put
together that the kids
were like a match genesis 23 and me like
they're they're spiraling yeah like
they're they don't understand this is
dizzy it's so crazy and weird um but i'm
happy and i saw a picture of the family
is like you know
unique looking and i think that's great
but also what's crazy is they all look
like twins obviously but they're not i
would be able to tell these people apart
if i spent enough time with them right
right but also
yeah yeah and the kids names are jett
and jax jackson claude that just seems
intentionally confusing no but they call
him jacks because it's short for jackson
claude oh and they call him jet for it's
because it's um short for the jets and
the sharks
right okay cool cool but they want like
to be this one big happy family well
good because it's the one they got
[Music]
um that's definitely you know you can
rely on people magazine for finding [ __ ]
like this and for that we're grateful to
them and the work that they do
which really i think it's like a
submission box on their website because
like every time when i'm in an airport
and i'm buying a magazine like i'm
usually gonna buy people because it's
the biggest it has the best pictures and
the best um crossword puzzle we'll find
a symmetry like do they have like hey
are you a freak like
do you they're literally the modern day
pt barnum like
like how do they find they're always
like man who was chained to a well for
65 years comes out with a 19 pound
scrotum like they always find this crazy
[ __ ]
hey are you free like no it's like those
signs p.t barnum in the movie yeah like
he was putting up like freaks dogs like
[Music]
that's what they do but i want to know
how do they um
gather these stories
they're hunters and gatherers yeah how
do they source the talent right because
i know for a fact like when you're
watching jerry springer like they have
an ad like do you want to be on our show
send an email like that's how they
source the information so i'm just
curious what people's method of sourcing
is that's all i was saying
it's simply i think though there's a box
that says hey are you a freak
if you scroll the website who isn't a
freak such a good girl who's not a
little freaky sometimes well we're about
to find out in deer toasters our weekly
advice segment where we try and help
three forlorn toasters come to the
conclusions that they need to come to
so dear toasters gmail.com is the email
if you want to write in thank you to
everyone for being you know open and
vulnerable with us in this time and
let's dive in hey jackson claude hey
love you guys and needed to write in to
ensure that i'm not overreacting about a
month ago my husband and i moved to a
new state and made a group of friends in
our neighborhood these friends are all
mostly couples and we really hit it off
the husbands and boyfriends in the group
decided they wanted to take a weekend
trip fishing flash forward to the
weekend of the trip while the wives and
girlfriends are at the neighborhood pool
one of the girlfriends mentions how
their man took mushrooms and coke on the
trip all the other women began to talk
and joke about how their men had told
them about it and how they thought it
was so funny meanwhile i'm completely
shocked as my husband didn't mention it
at all i was seemingly the only wife who
hadn't been told naturally i discreetly
texted my husband and asked and within a
few minutes one of the other wives gets
a text from their husband
it basically says he was just told by my
husband that i wasn't happy about the
drugs she announced to the group what
the text said and completely embarrassed
me my husband says he did not partake
and he didn't mention it to me because
he didn't want to get in any get anyone
in trouble as he didn't know that the
other husbands had told their wives do i
have the right to feel like my husband
lied to me why would he have more
loyalty to these new friends than he has
to me i'm frustrated by the whole
situation but i also struggle with
coming off as a losery wife hell
sincerely a toaster who's avoiding the
neighborhood pool and her husband today
wait i know you're like mad at like the
husband thing but like i would be more
mad that he literally like ratted on you
to the other women yeah that's what i
would be mad about who cares if you're
the losery wife by the way being the
wife who doesn't want her husband doing
mushrooms and coke like that's something
crazy like that's fine yeah what would
bother me is like you got a text from me
showing my concern about something and
you showed it to all the other guys
that's like an invasion of privacy
that's just like
it's a lapse in judgment assuming he's a
good man and you love him and i'm sure
that he is those things because he's
your husband it's a lapse in judgment
where he got carried away like you know
this is a new group of friends like i'm
going to show them like my you know i
got the ball and chase yeah right how
she feels um and that's you need to be
like
never again like that's him not
considering you at all like how that
makes you look how that makes the other
women feel about you like that part
would piss me off more yeah than the
drugs thing the drugs thing wouldn't
piss me off because i couldn't like if
it were my husband first of all
maybe he didn't know about it going into
it he's not going to do it there and
when he comes home he'll be like by the
way the guys did this and that's right
he doesn't need to like report to you
and be like mom there's drugs in the
trip like right we're grown people i
personally wouldn't think so especially
if he if he's not doing it but if he's
doing those things
and wasn't going to tell you like till
after i think that's a little dishonest
but if it's just there i think it's
totally fine that he didn't tell you yet
i would assume though eventually he
would yeah no and i guess like maybe
you're not upset about the text thing
but like i am that really would bother
me yeah and then like the other girl
like reading it i didn't send a text to
the group right the other text to you
the other girl reading it like out loud
to everyone like that's so [ __ ]
obnoxious of her by the way but it's 100
your husband's fault and like you need
to explain that to him and i'm all for
you guys like having this cup like you
move to a new place you found couples
that you like you have like the girls
and the guys the sharks and the jets but
something about this is like a little um
like high school a grade and i just
think you should keep your friends and
and whatever but just mentally like take
us a one
sliver of a step back yes don't get too
involved with all of this it really
showed you like the negative side of the
group so just keep that in mind like you
don't have to not be friends with them
anymore but like i wouldn't tell
everyone your deepest darkest secrets
because obviously this group is [ __ ]
chatty as [ __ ] yeah but it sounds like a
fun group you know like fishing pools
mushrooms coke ah and fun fun sounds
like a book it does and that's like the
first red flag thing that happens where
like the [ __ ] girl in the group her
name is always margot it's always marco
i mean she was like
did you tell your husband
and like you're embarrassed but you're
like no margo didn't mean it it was just
miscommunication right right she would
never margo next thing you know margo's
bar burying a body in the woods 100
that's always how it happens that's
always how it happens and it's always
margo all right next up hey ladies i'll
try to keep this short and sweet but
i've got a situation on my hands my
fiance and i are getting married in
september and my fiance's parents have
graciously agreed to pay for our entire
wedding and honeymoon i seriously can't
believe i'm actually getting my dream
wedding and it's really all thanks to
them the only thing is my boyfriend just
nervously told me his parents will be
joining us for our honeymoon
it is so nice that they're paying for
everything but them coming on our
honeymoon is insane
lotus white lotus my husband agrees but
is also too scared to say anything do i
suck it up everything is already booked
so it's just a horrible predicament i'm
in and i don't know what to do please
help out a fellow floridian toaster
eek that's like really manipulative it's
not a honeymoon yeah no and normally
like i'm all for you know putting on a
smile just to get what you want um and
if she was being like a monster about
the wedding i would be like you know
what she's paying for it just like shut
up but honeymoon is taking it a little
too fast i don't think there's one
person watching uh or who would hear
this story who would think that that's a
normal thing to do no you absolutely uh
can't let her come and you also cannot
say anything your boyfriend has to and
your boyfriend also has to be the one to
like claim it was his idea not you like
it'll make you look bad this is what in
the engagement process like it is
important to note that like any
communication between a bride and the
in-laws must go through the husband and
be like the husband's original idea and
then the communication between the
husband and the in-laws should go
through the groom and it should be like
the bride and be like the bride's idea
like the communication during the
engagement process is really delicate so
your husband absolutely has to be the
one to break it to his parents that they
cannot come and it has he can't be like
oh sarah said she didn't want you to
come and like sell you down the river
like moses but
but that's what engagements and like
planning a wedding and all of these
things it's actually like a trial of for
marriage you have like micro courses and
all these different things communication
in-laws finances planning this that and
it's really a test and
now you're being put to the test will
you pass yeah i'll see you can't let
this go like you absolutely have to do
something about it i mean what's the
point of going on the honeymoon anyway
save your money and stay home and take a
check like oh or you get the family
together for like family night and you
watch white lotus and you'll be like
that's crazy a mom going on someone's
honeymoon that's funny if if the other
way doesn't work try that
or just stay home be like oh that's my
option i'll stay home thanks for the
wedding girl at least we get have
private alone time together
that's insane by the way insane um okay
we have one more deer toasters and it's
brought to you by modern fertility we've
always been big fans of planning ahead
scheduling trips plotting our career
moves figuring out what we're doing for
dinner
but we've never well i have never given
much thought to planning for kids but
that's why modern fertility was created
it's an easy and affordable way to test
your fertility hormones at home with a
simple finger prick you mail it with a
prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within 10 days
you'll get insight into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve
and your other important fertility
factors the results go deep into what
every hormone means and you can also
download the results to review with your
doctor for next steps traditional
testing can cost over a thousand dollars
but modern fertility gets you the same
information at a fraction of the price
and if you go to modernfertility.com
toast you can get 20 off your test so
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com
toast that means your test will cost 179
instead of the hundreds or even
thousands it could cost at a doctor's
office get 20 off your fertility test
when you go to modernfertility.com
toast
modernfertility.com
toast
all right final dear toaster is a little
lengthy hey jackson claude
i'm married to an amazing man and i have
the greatest relationship with his
parents they've been so helpful with the
baby and are over the moon excited since
this is their first grandchild when it
comes to what they want to be called as
grandparents i think it should be up to
the child and see what cute nicknames
they come up with however my
mother-in-law has given herself the name
of mama she never asked me if i think
it's okay and i feel like i'm going
crazy that no one else finds it weird
she is now constantly referring to
herself in the third person as mama and
she's even gone as far as wearing
jewelry that says mama on it every time
i hear her say mama my stomach drops
i've never wanted to be called mommy
i've always preferred the name mama for
myself it's what i call my own mother i
mentioned this a year ago when the
conversation was brought up before i was
even pregnant but it seems to be
forgotten or ignored i find it so rude
that she is taking the name
from me and she doesn't find it strange
i'm losing sleep over this issue and
thinking of when my baby starts to speak
and their first word will be mama and my
mother-in-law will claim that it's about
her she also makes comments about how
it's her baby and how the baby just
looks like her and my husband it's like
her first grandchild so i get the
obsession but it's my first baby also
and i feel as though she's taking all of
this from me i feel like i might explode
one day and i don't want to build up
resentment what i want to say is listen
[ __ ] i carried this baby for nine
months my body will never be the same it
feeds off of my tits and i haven't slept
in months i am mama say it i am mama but
i hate comfort confrontation more than
anything
wait sorry i hate confrontation more
than anyone so that would never happen
but it's how i feel i do love my
mother-in-law and i see how much joy my
child brings her so i can never say
anything to hurt her feelings i also
don't want to make this a big thing by
bringing it up to my husband and i'm
worried it would upset him even though i
have a feeling he would agree with me i
just don't want him to think i'm not
grateful for his mom who does so much
for us please help sincerely she ain't
your mama blow it up girl no this is
another thing your husband has to take
care of this wench for sure and i feel
like he might be like oh i thought it
was weird too but you didn't say
anything so i thought you were fine with
it this is not okay this is not
acceptable not normal to stop especially
before your baby can actually speak and
it's confused like who is my mom right
mama is only for the mother she could be
called grandmama if that's what she
wants but you need to put your foot down
now if you really can't find a way it
doesn't have to be confrontational you
don't have to scream at her but if you
can't find a way to voice how you're
feeling to her then tell your husband
that he has to do it because if this is
making you lose sleep at night like as
new mamas we have so much on our plate
so many things that you worry about as
you're falling asleep at night you can't
also be worried about who does my child
think is his mama because my
mother-in-law is feeling like you know
it's she somehow is no no no
no no and you know what i'm glad you
wrote into us because if you've been
experiencing this like on your own maybe
you're not entirely sure you're
overreacting but i hope that the very
strong reaction jackie and i have had
and i'm sure people in the comments will
have will empower you to be like no no
i'm not crazy like i'm justified in
being angry this is psychotic and you
must nip it in the body psychotic
psychotic and simply if even after being
spoken to like she's not accepting like
there is a psycho in your presence
100 100 percent get rid of her like you
get rid of her also as a new mama like
if anything is bothering you even if
whether you're justified or not like
it it has to go right whatever it is it
has to go because you have too much
going on especially like you're
breastfeeding it's can't you can't
tolerate things that do not serve you
but this is not even
an art for treasury like is it okay is
it not okay sort of thing you're 100
justified everything you feel is valid
get rid of her
get rid of her
yeah you say you call yourself mama in
my house one more time it's the last
time in my house until the jewelry until
you the jewelry like i'm in like i'm
embarrassed like
embarrassed i feel shame for her
the jewelry
it feels like she's definitely working
out some like unresolved trauma from her
youth because this is this is like
seriously like psychotic behavior
like i say to harry like i'm your mom
like as a [ __ ] joke like i know it's
psychotic
yeah wait did you write this in about me
no
no this is
did you okay where's your jewelry
that's a good call um this is really
like unwell behavior and you must
address it immediately your husband
specifically like
whatever route is the easiest for you to
address it whether it's a letter in the
mail i don't really the delivery does
not matter here just the message i
agreed agree message must be received
and those were the three dear toaster
submissions i would like to thank
everyone who wrote in um we hope you we
hope you helped i feel like we gave good
advice i feel like we did you also these
were um
morally clear yeah there wasn't like an
ambiguity of like what to do
so if you want to write in for next
week's episode deartoasters gmail.com
that is our show thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio pass box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
morning each other leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing wednesday don't forget to hump
someone you love and we'll see you
tomorrow for thursday's episode goodbye